welcome to world stories your
international reporters magazine im sue
me somas ganda and this week we'll
explore the tradition of the shi'a cap
in tunisia will harness the Earth's heat
in el salvador and we go fishing in
Istanbul all that and more coming up but
first India's been described as a land
of paradoxes a place of extreme wealth
and abject poverty of Eastern tradition
and Western ambitions but over the past
decade India has proven its strength as
an emerging economic power and Mumbai
its biggest city is at the heart of that
growth there a wave of young
entrepreneurs are helping to reshape the
image of india abroad and that's where
Molony Agarwal comes in she's one of
mumbai's favorite socialites and she's
turned her knack for all things
Bollywood and fashion into a successful
career emerging stars TV reporter Bipin
Chandra chedule sits down with Malini
and shares this story the city of Mumbai
is regarded as the commercial center of
India it's also the hometown of the
world famous bollywood film industry
mullen iago wall has been called the
Paris Hilton of India a few years ago
the former radio DJ decided to take her
interest in entertainment one step
further her blog called missmalini
explores the glamorous worlds of fashion
show biz celebrities and more it started
small but has since become an internet
sensation
so my business is actually a really fun
online blog which focuses on fashion
Bollywood and nightlife Bollywood being
the biggest thing that everybody's into
in India it's sort of like an online
magazine so it's very real time its
virtual so it's taking everything that
newspapers did in terms of gossip or
magazines do in terms of fashion and
turning it over much faster with a lot
more multimedia video tweet social media
and giving people real-time information
on everything that's happening with
their favorite celebrities and what's
happening in fashion
first I started just as a hobby like I
said just for fun and then very slowly
very quickly sorry I realized that
people were very interested in what we
were doing and and we suddenly got a lot
of feedback and a lot of brands started
contacting me saying hey can you write
about my product can you come cover my
then and so we realized that hang on I'm
you know I've done zero investment I'm
already getting incoming revenue maybe
we're onto something here and then my
husband who went to Harvard put his
brains to it we decided let's let's do
this and we got one round of you know
sort of seed funding initial funding i'm
not sure what it's called but i'm angel
funding and we took off when she started
doing this hobby blog and you start
getting interest and she started getting
interest from investors you know a it
was a natural point for me to get
involved to help her out and then as we
explore it further and further and saw
potential you know when we looked into
how big blogging is as an industry in
the US for example and then you think
about where india is going to be from an
internet market standpoint and the fact
the blogging industry here definitely
exists at least not in the entertainment
space it was just that's what I realize
know that that the idea that I was
looking for the business I was looking
for kind of walked in to my
and it was very exciting maybe it so
once we had that support from investors
that's my news type big chance
nowadays missmalini cooperates with both
large companies and small local
entrepreneurs like this mumbai-based
fashion designer right from the
beginning of my brand I wanted to do a
really great launch for my brand and the
only person I could think of was Miss
Molly need to do that and I think well
he'll help we did this brilliant launch
we did three fashion flash mobs in like
the best clubs in Bombay and it was such
a success and after that I think it's
just been an ongoing you know radiation
that we've been in so it works well for
both of us and what we like to do is
this miss malini I want to align with
brands that are cool and funky and
represent the missmalini culture and so
sure because brand Papa don't preach is
exactly that it is sort of bold and
beautiful and edgy so it just goes so
well with my brand so great for both of
us so I get the revenue she gets the
promotion it's an ongoing relationship
and so the miss malini brand becomes a
mascot for Papa don't preach and it
works and we love dressing up so
anything that money anyways is just an
instant hit anyway with the reader so it
works really went for that
what started as a hobby has turned into
a serious business there are 10
permanent members of staff in the office
either blogging or working on the sales
side but mullah nyaka wall remains the
driving force behind the company's
success her colleagues say her energy
and dedication are boundless the energy
that she brings is is really infectious
and the number one question I get asked
by people about Melanie is where she
gets her energy from and I have no idea
it's partially from Red Bull I suppose
but there's gotta be more to it than
that because she just works harder than
anyone I know and most people I think
suspect that the blog is not that much
work just put up the stories people
understand that Molony is is blogging
for the minute she wakes up she's
covering event she's getting her hair
and makeup she's meeting interviewing
celebrities and then after that when she
gets home at one two three o'clock in
the morning then she continues blogging
to make sure that everything is up in a
timely fashion so the mount and
intensity that she works with is is what
drives the business hi are watching this
money you don't know I'm so excited
we're going to do our first and only
rice before the show is over Showtime
and put them on
mullen he has big dreams for the blog
she thinks it could even change how the
outside world sees india i think the
dream is to really put india on the map
in a way that's not Slumdog Millionaire
that's not discovery channel in the
villages of India to put modern India on
the map and be a representative of the
new age the new wave I like to call
myself a social media Jedi and I like
the idea that coming out of you know
this culture as opposed to everything
coming from the West her vision
competence and passion have certainly
put her blog on the map and she herself
has become a regular fixture on the
glamorous Hollywood celebrity circuit
well from forward fashion to a
traditional garment that's falling out
of favor in Tunisia the Shakya is a
round brim lyst cap usually in black or
red that dates back hundreds of years
making sure sheís is a special craft
that was once highly valued as part of
Tunisia's cultural heritage but nowadays
the symbolic hat has lost its luster and
its importance in society tunisia News
Network reporter so here L shibani
brings us this story not far from the
presidential palace in the casbah
district of Tunis Abdul Razak Katya is
laying out his where's the 70 year old
is also manager of the old shoe Shia
market which was once a thriving hub for
the making and sale of traditional
Tunisian headwear I'm today with me
Norah beans in nineteen forty two and
three there were four hundred and eighty
shishir makers at the market here in
Tunis and now there are only twenty
uncle my made back in the day the market
spilled over into four venues but with a
number of people practicing the craft
these days and we'd be lucky to open
half a market definite Kozma was so
holla kabira so closely
this is the face of the Shishir market
today now that so many craftsmen have
left to pursue other more lucrative
lines of work in the restaurant and
tourist trades hafez flesh sits in his
painted wooden shop putting the
finishing touches to his shishio's he's
one of just a handful of people who have
not turned their backs on what was once
an esteemed profession
and the show is she want him I Misha
Shia maker I learned the craft from my
father who in turn learned it from his
father even as a very young child i
accompanied my father who has since
passed away jamala i really enjoy the
craft [ __ ] nice honest he assured me the
Shakya makers who are still active
lament the fact that so many tunisia ins
have either turned their backs on the
traditional garment or prefer to wear
the factory made variety knoxville uh
montavilla almost no one comes to buy
new sure she is these days demand is
nothing like it used to be we no longer
have the same materials that were
originally used LOL a much more suitable
cutter came up and young people are not
interested in going into the profession
boos my dad as far as they're concerned
it's too demanding and requires too much
patience totally possible Nestle mash
still be fewer people whereas Ashiya
these days with them our season is three
months long and runs from december to
februari when it's hot you can't wear a
shishir anyway okely onion even I have
to stop wearing mine in March we might
have said generally speaking I'd say
they've become less important
maliciously Abdul Azad Zack cahya
believes the government could do more to
support his profession although it has
pledged its help so far no concrete
action has been taken is it in nigeria
nigeria number like for years we've been
asking the government to help save our
profession from extinction we've
received repeated promises but nothing's
been done amiss and at that to me every
other profession has received help just
not ours and we don't know why unleash
medical is odd
although some Tunisian still believe in
the symbolic importance of the headpiece
many younger people in particular feel
life has moved beyond it shabbona many
young people only wear shishya on
special occasions where the shoulder
people wear them more often well yes or
no maybe is marginally don't wear sure
she is anymore they're not widely worn
in today's Tunisian society mr. Martin's
o Muhammad muchas ashiya won't die out
it's a special Tunisian craft just like
the craft of leather working or
shoemaking ashiya making is part of our
cultural heritage alum sanity but there
is life for the shishir beyond tunisia
important export countries are Libya
Nigeria and Niger and there's hope it
will beat off the competition of modern
headwear flooding the market Shh a halt
men to stone Samantha seal ah the Shia
is a unique Tunisian headpiece that has
existed for a very long time that is
complicated to make it will survive
despite the current difficulties and
perhaps there will be people interested
in helping to keep it alive Siravo
calatrava Marta mammoth musica cinema
too much bahala lay the shishir dates
back to the 14th century it's typical
deep red is symbolic of the many social
and political revolutions the country
has experienced some of them not so long
ago food security means physical and
economic access to the most basic food
needed to survive it's amazing then to
think that almost one in eight people in
the world struggled with chronic hunger
over the past two years it's a pervasive
problem in the developing world
especially where rising food prices and
climate change have had a dramatic
effect on farming and basic nutrition
Namibia is prone to droughts but it's
now in the grips of the worst dry spell
in decades as un TV Suzanne buchs shows
us aid workers are doing their best to
relieve the suffering but they face an
uphill battle
this dry and dusty sand is all that
remains of carrion ah KU zhu couches
maze in vegetable field oh we are hungry
that is the impact of the drought that
is what we can see people are hungry
people are dying and yada oh I don't
know about you you have no clue that you
want to do she now has just one week
supply of maize remaining after that
she's not sure how she will find food to
feed her family karriem aku Jews dire
situation is the result of the worst
drought Namibia has experienced in 30
years an estimated 780,000 Namibians or
a third of the population are now
severely or moderately food insecure in
May the government declared an emergency
committing around 20 million u.s.
dollars to provide food and water to
affected people aid agencies have also
stepped in to help unicef namibia
representative Michaela marques de Souza
twenty-nine percent of children in this
country are stunted and stunting is
irreversible it means twenty-nine
percent of this children do not do well
in schools it means twenty-nine percent
of these children actually full out of
the system so children and women are
bearing the brunt of the drought
in response UNICEF is scaling up water
sanitation and hygiene facilities as
well as nutrition education and infant
feeding activities neozen unit is chief
of health and nutrition UNICEF Namibia
Namibia has been experiencing the
cyclical challenges of droughts and
floods so the government as well as the
international community should really
work hands in hands were to really
prevent the further deterioration of the
climate change problem you know
resulting in an natural disasters ambit
eh Pazza an elder in the ovahimba
community has seen her fair share of
droughts but two consecutive years of no
rain in her village in kunin a region is
taking its toll from previous years we
never suffered from drought because we
used to drink milk and eat whatever we
wanted to now the drought is really
affecting us am Betty boils a watery
maize porridge her only meal for the day
the government food rations have not yet
arrived and she must support several
families on her meager resources as in
years before the community is willing to
wait out the drought but it remains to
be seen if they will have the strength
to do so if help doesn't come soon el
salva-dork may be the smallest country
in Central America but it sure makes up
for its size in its sheer number of
volcanoes there are 22 to be exact now
deep below the earth those volcanoes
carry incredible potential in the form
of geothermal energy now engineers have
started to harness that heat to provide
environmentally friendly energy and
slash the country's co2 emissions that's
become especially important in El
Salvador as climate change has started
to take its toll reporter Manuel a
circus visited the south of the country
after devastating torrential rain struck
two years ago and he shows us how that's
burden effort to go green take a look
a few books are all that remains of the
school in commerce agua a town near the
capital of El Salvador few days before
this was filmed a torrential rainfall
triggered a landslide that destroyed the
building it's the only school in the
area and it's now in ruins many homes
across our Salvador have been destroyed
by mudslides more than a hundred people
died during the last rainy season
where's that fair water for cake oh boy
I'm afraid it will keep getting worse we
probably can't stay here we'll have to
move if it starts raining again we'll
have to leave right away Sally repair
lighting melly Otto people here believe
they're feeling the impact of climate
change the government hopes clean
geothermal energy will help counter its
effects here in the municipality of
Berlin is one of the two main plants
producing geothermal energy power
generated from underground volcanic
steam now covers a quarter of El
Salvador's electricity needs brine
assurer from the German Association for
international cooperation is helping to
make even more efficient use of this
energy
he meets with oscar salvador bahia the
manager of the lafayette GA thermal
plant one of the plants Wells is 2,600
meters deep and the other goes down 1100
meters the plant generates a large part
of the country's energy but it could
produce even more steam escaping from
the plants turbines is now being wasted
the engineer is looking for ways to
capture it drilling new wells would also
increase capacity but drilling is very
capital intensive choix is helping
lacayo find a company that can drill
more cheaply Lila hell no Sarah Corrado
we have these two plants now but we're
planning more right now we're checking
out two additional drilling fields then
we have four fields in all we want to
increase our market share now we're
covering a quarter of the market but we
want to expand amo mas SE como stai
ferrando those come from us the
resources are available so we'll
definitely build more so now we're
examining two additional fields
volcanic Hot Springs are common in
seismically active el salvador in some
villages families even washed their
clothes in the hot water even though the
water smells of sulfur it's very useful
what get wound up my lava washing is
much faster and because the water is so
hot we don't have to use much soap just
a short distance away the hot springs
are even more impressive here at the
foot of the takapa volcano hot water is
bubbling to the surface geothermal power
could potentially supply all of the
country's energy needs sustainably with
no increase in co2 emissions
there are 22 active volcanoes in El
Salvador but only a small fraction of
that volcanic energy is currently being
harnessed a few businesses in El
Salvador are beginning to benefit from
geothermal energy this nursery is
planning to move some of its green
houses near a geothermal plant that will
allow them to use the cheaper
electricity they held talks with the
plant's operator
we have to negotiate with them they
offer this very very special price for
us it's green electricity down the
geothermal plant so we don't have to
worry about any co2 emission co2
emissions okay it's a green energy for
electricity and also the heat energy for
the our electricity bill is about 40,000
US dollars per month this electricity is
mainly used for ventilators for pumps
for cooling systems and in eating we
spent about four hundred thousand
dollars on oil per year we will
definitely save money but it's also
important for us to produce in a cleaner
and a more sustainable way it's not only
about money they also hope to be a role
model for other companies in the region
hot springs are abundant in Central
America and that means there's an
abundance of green energy just waiting
for someone to tap into it and finally
if you've ever visited Istanbul it's a
site you've likely seen crowds of
tourists and locals alike gathered under
the famous galata bridge to taste the
city's favorite delicacy freshly cooked
fish it's a tradition that survived the
ages and became a part of assembles lore
Bulgaria's nova TV reporter dan Uggla
chef shows us more
it's a city on two continents split down
the middle by the Bosphorus Strait and
flanked by the black sea and the sea of
marmara its waterside location makes
Istanbul of fish lovers paradise boom
boom there's a lot of fish around the
city's iconic galata bridge and in the
restaurants on its lower level our guide
is Jae hoon a man who knows fish well we
take the fish from dogfish mark there's
any any of that all the morning is at
altar five o'clock six o'clock all the
fish coming from the prosperous and the
marmara sea and off to the other see for
example sort of Turkey in Mediterranean
but what people here really love is
extremely fresh fish cooked in the
traditional Istanbul way also there was
a traditional patient bread this is very
famous on the emanator because this is a
like a traditional style when people
about three times they take the
children's and friends or girlfriends or
wives they're coming same another they
take our mission trip you think are this
fish caught minutes ago and the Golden
Horn has ended up in a tasty sandwich
with onions and traditional Turkish
bread shrimps are also netted under the
bridge these chefs are peeling them in
preparation for cooking and serving
though not all of them make it that far
and how does jae-hoon feel about the
dozens of fishermen who lined the bridge
at the mouth of the Bosphorus
usually it's good there's a nice weave
when you a lots of fisherman fishing
here is a nice view but a little bit
dangerous with its air pollution
industry and population of almost 14
million people Istanbul is a modern city
but it's also a place where tradition
indoors and where fresh fish is an
inextricable part of life well that's
all for this edition of world stories
will leave you now with this week's pics
of the world see you next time